bonjour à tous donc j'ai le plaisir de
vous présenter
lydia guirous ce qui est nouveau binôme
dans le cadre du porte parolat pour les
républicains
et donc je lui souhaite la bienvenue et
isabelle le callennec m'a chargé de vous
saluer tous de dire qu'elle avait eu
beaucoup de plaisir à travailler avec
vous et que maintenant dans ses
nouvelles fonctions qui est d'être avec
eric woerth pour la préparation du
projet alors grand plaisir vous revoir à
l'occasion des futures conventions
qu'elle organisera donc avec eric y est
donc
elle m'a demandé donc de vous passer ce
petit message amical alors nous allons
comptiez commencer tout de suite avec le
traditionnel âge as tu as de la semaine
donc aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy est en
déplacement en israël
il profitera d'ailleurs de de ceux de ce
déplacement pour rencontrer la
fédération des républicains d'israël
demain mardi nous aurons à 17 heures ici
au siège le bureau politique
attention le bureau politique est
avancée d'une heure c'est à la demande
d'ailleurs de françois fillon qui ne
pouvait pas être la plus tard il avait
un déplacement donc il a demandé à
nicolas sarkozy de bien vouloir avancer
ce bureau politique donc il aura lieu à
17 heures à huis clos comme d'habitude à
18h30 j'aurai le plaisir donc demain de
d'animer un débat de l'alternance sur le
thème de quels défis pour les nouveaux
républicains ensuite mercredi 10 juin
aura lieu à 11 heures
sous la présidence de nicolas sarkozy
une réunion avec les chefs de file pour
les élections régionales à 18h30
un autre débat de l'alternance qui sera
animée par pierre yves bournazel
conseiller de paris et conseiller
régional d'île de france sur le thème
des élections régionales
nous sommes en route pour la victoire il
ya 19 heures nicolas sarkozy tiendra une
réunion publique à puteaux au théâtre
des hauts-de-seine 5 rue henri martin et
samedi 13 juin à 10h30
nicolas sarkozy recevra les nouveaux
adhérents des républicains voilà pour ce
qui est de l'agenda vous avez vu que les
républicains s'organiser puisque un
certain nombre de nominations ont eu
lieu donc secrétaires généraux
porte-parole secrétaires généraux
adjoints avec comme maître mot celui de
la parité et donc vous avez eue c'est
une nouvelle nomination d'autres
nominations vont avoir lieu dans les
jours qui viennent
toujours sur le principe de la parité et
notamment la nomination des nouveaux
secrétaires nationaux vous allez voir de
nouveaux visages
et puis la volonté de structurer notre
formation politique en
une organisation pour un parti de masse
avec une organisation à la fois sur le
thème de la réflexion des comités
notamment comité d'entrepreneurs à
l'image du comité des mères qui existait
déjà dans l'ancien ump et puis une
volonté de structuration sur le terrain
pour attirer à nous de nombreux
adhérents
je parlais par exemple du comité des
entrepreneurs où nous souhaitons que
certain nombre d'entrepreneurs de notre
pays que ce soit de pme ou de grandes
entreprises viennent participer avec
nous à l'élaboration du projet
économique des républicains
ce comité des entrepreneurs doit
fonctionner de la même manière que le
comité des mères c'est à voir c'est à
dire d'avoir eu autour de nous des gens
qui ont envie de participer à la
réflexion sans forcément prendre leur
carte leur carte pardon dans notre
formation politique
ils viennent participer et puis si ils
s'y sentent bien peut-être que ils
franchiront le pas de deux d'adhérer aux
républicains mais en tout cas ce que
nous voulons c'est d'abord les associer
à notre réflexion pour bâtir le projet
d'airé public et donc avec cette volonté
d'associer le maximum de gens et
notamment de professionnels vous avez pu
voir qu'il y avait eu dans la nomination
des secrétaires généraux adjoints 1
secrétaire-général adjoint en charge des
fédérations professionnelles
notre volonté est vraiment de développer
ses fédérations professionnelles secteur
par secteur afin là aussi de pouvoir non
seulement développer notre réseau de
républicains partout sur le territoire
mais aussi d'avoir et bien dans les
différents secteurs de notre économie
des gens qui ont envie à la fois de
s'engager et de faire des propositions
dans le cadre de la préparation de
l'alternance
voyez c'est quelque chose qui nous tient
à coeur cette organisation qui soit à la
fois une structuration sur le plan des
idées mais aussi
structuration sur le terrain bon ce week
end a eu lieu le congrès socialiste à
poitiers bon il est vrai qu'on n'a pas
grand chose sur le fond à retenir de ce
congrès il a brillé par l'absence
d'idées l'absence de perspectives aussi
pour la france
et puis des divisions qui ne se sont
malgré la violence des propos de manuel
valls et de jean christophe cambadélis
des divisions qu'ils n'ont pas réussi à
cacher donc on peut dire que manuel
valls a échoué sur tous les plans il a
échoué parce qu'il nous démontre bien
son incapacité à diriger la france et
son incapacité aussi à rassembler sa
famille politique
on a des fondeurs qu'on a voulu faire
taire
lors de ce congrès l'un d'entre eux
arnaud montebourg s'est fendu d'une
d'une tribune avec matthieu pigasse dans
le jdd
là encore les frondeurs on peut avoir
l'impression alors qu'un remaniement
approche un mini remaniement approche
que les frondeurs essaye de se
positionner
alors est-ce que l'intérêt politique va
prendre le dessus sur sur leurs
convictions
on va le on va le voir donc absence
d'idées pas de rassemblement la seule
parade qui a trouvé
manuel valls a été de l'agressivité
l'excès et le mépris vis-à-vis du
président nicolas sarkozy et du premier
parti de l'opposition
manuel valls ne supporte pas la
contradiction et nouvelle vache ne
supporte pas le débat d'idées et tombe
dans la violence finalement la violence
de manuel valls est à la hauteur de la
vacuité de son bilan
moi ça ça m'amuse parce que manuel valls
se revendique très souvent de clemenceau
le tigre et ce week-end on a plutôt eu
l'impression de voir un petit chat
apeuré et ne leur lors de ce congrès je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut lui
rappeler que l'opposition est de retour
que nous nous structurons qu'une faisons
un travail de fond sur les idées mais
également sur le maillage territorial et
professionnels et sébastien l'a rappelé
et que là pour garantir la démocratie il
faut que l'opposition soit respectée
nous serons là sans arrêt organisés et
prêts à répondre à chacune des mesures
que prendra le gouvernement et qui à
notre sens va dans le mauvais sens si on
peut regarder quand même que ce soit les
chiffres du chômage de la croissance ou
de la dette
bon donc voilà c'est c'était aussi
amusant peut le relever de voir un
premier ministre qui a passé trop qui
était trois fois au congrès à poitiers
on se demande s'il est le premier
ministre de tous les français oui si
seulement il est le premier ministre des
socialistes donc là dessus c'est un
point qui me semble assez gênant on l'a
vu se déplacer une fois pour aller un
match de foot aucune aucune équipe
française n'était engagée donc c'était
c'était à berlin et puis ensuite le
dimanche à roland garros on voit là
c'est le spectacle d'un d'un premier
ministre qui est bien loin des réalités
et on a l'impression qu'ils ne touchent
plus le sol épuisé par ailleurs on peut
on peut se demander qui payent qui paye
tout tous ses déplacements
il aurait pu se rendre donc c3 c3
déplacement à poitiers il aurait pu les
faire en train ou en voiture
voilà donc ce sont ce sont des points
qui nous on a que nous que nous
souhaitons soulevées sur sur ce congrès
socialiste et sur les attaques
le manuel pages concernant les attaques
de jean christophe cambadélis je crois
qu'il n'y a pas véritablement besoin de
relever on connaît son bagage
universitaire ce grand doctorants donc
la pertinence de sa comparaison sera
sera la république de nicolas sarkozy je
crois qu'on n'a pas de leçon d'histoire
à recevoir de monsieur cambadélis et
nous nous ne céderons rien sur les
valeurs de la république nous ne
céderons rien de notre combat pour la
république et il va falloir que la
gauche s'y habitue voilà il dit à la 10e
quand vous avez un million de chômeurs
supplémentaires en trois ans lorsque
vous avez déficit des déficits qui
dérape
je vous rappelle ce qu'a dit la cour des
comptes il ya quelques jours 10 millions
10 milliards pardon d'euros
supplémentaires qui manquent dans les
caisses de l'état quand vous avez
l'insécurité galopante avec le
désarmement pénale organisée par le
gouvernement
on peut se poser la question de savoir
comment monsieur valls a le temps
d'aller trois jours au congrès du ps
comment il a le temps d'aller sur les
marches de cannes comment il a le temps
d'aller à la finale de la champion s
league comment il a le temps d'aller à
la finale de roland garros on a
l'impression que le premier ministre
préfère aller dans tous les événements
people de la planète plutôt que de
s'occuper des difficultés des français
des français qui souffrent à cause de la
politique délétère qui est menée donc
c'est une vraie question
quelles sont les priorités et de
monsieur valls est ce que ce sont sa
priorité c'est de trouver des solutions
pour sortir la france de l'ornière dans
laquelle il l'a précipitée ou est ce que
c'est d'aller se faire mousser sur les
épaules sur les estrades
ou dans les événements people il semble
qu'il ait choisi la deuxième solution et
c'est pas ce qu'attendent relais
français d'un premier ministre de la
france notamment dans la situation dans
laquelle on est et alors qu'on a les
chiffres du chômage comme le soulever
sébastien qui qui atteignent des sommets
avec une france qui décrochent
totalement y compris au niveau européen
voilà la seule chose que nous propose le
gouvernement c'est le traitement social
du chômage
moi j'ai toujours entendu pour les
jeunes alors les contrats aidés les
emplois jeunes et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui faut trouver d'autres
éléments
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage elle
se fera pas avec 100000 emplois et des
de plus qui vont peser très lourdement
sur le budget et puis lors de lors de ce
congrès on a on a quand même pu
remarquer que manuel valls qui cherchait
absolument les applaudissements n'a
surtout pas nommé son ministre de
l'économie manuel macron alors qu'un
autre banquier d'affaires lui faisait la
leçon sur sa politique économique
aujourd'hui les socialistes sont
totalement perte de repères idéologiques
ils doivent faire appel à des banquiers
d'affaires pour avoir leur lors leur
ligne économique puis par ailleurs quand
même arnaud montebourg était quand même
ministre
il s'est chargé du redressement
productif de la france il a également sa
part de responsabilité donc donc voilà
on est on est on est assez stupéfait du
spectacle que nous a donnée le parti
socialiste ce week end